Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, podcast du vor mit Florentiz und Stefan Wimorek. Zu spezifisch um Ausgedacht. Hallo, herzlich willkommen. Da habt ihr uns kurz erwischt bei unserem Intro-Chat. Ein kleiner Blick hinter die Kulissen des Podcast-Opus. Anders als der Blick vor den Kulissen, wo ja alles immer so glatt gebügelt ist. Da war der Vorhang kurz etwas zu niedrig und man hat uns noch gesehen, unsere nackten Unterschenkel, wie wir hinter der Bühne herumgewetzt sind. Wie wir eigentlich sprechen auch. Ja, eigentlich sprechen wir ganz anders. Wir lassen ja immer unsere Sprecherstimmen hier auf für unseren Podcast. Ja. Der da die ganze Zeit schon die ganze Zeit losbrabbelt, das ist der Florentin Will. Richtig, mir gegenüber sitzt natürlich Stefan Tiptop-Tieze aufgeräumt, sitzt hier parat und wen ihr gerade gehört habt, das war Lenny, wen wir gerade beleidigt haben während des Intros, als ihr nicht zugehört habt. Stellt euch immer vor, dass wir während des Intros das Intro beleidigen. Nicht so natürlich Lenny, der dieses fantastische Intro beigesteuert hat. Danke. Boah, du hast echt so eine Frank-Elzner-artige Moderation. Das ist so eklig, wie du diese Dinge wegmoderierst. Das ist krank, ohne Kanten, ohne Persönlichkeit. Du hast einfach so ein Moderationsblabla drauf. Das ist insane. Das hat mir Frank Elstner beigebracht. Man darf keine Kanten haben. Er meinte auch, wenn du moderierst, deine Silhouette darf keine Kanten haben. Du darfst nicht die Arme so rausstrecken, du darfst keine Kanten haben. Ja, aber das habe ich mir bebehalten. Genau, das hast du auch für deine Moderation drauf geschafft, wo jegliche Persönlichkeit und Edginess weg ist. Einfach nur ein vielen Dank an Lennart für das Wort.
Irgendwas klar.
Du, mittlerweile, seitdem hier Moderationskarten geschrieben werden, ist mir das alles völlig egal.
Die werden Moderationskarten geschrieben.
Kommen wir also zu unserer ersten Rubrik.
Zum ersten Witz der Folge.
Stefan, du hast erlebt.
Kann ich dir mal ganz offen was sagen? Ich mag Frank Elstner nicht. Wie, du magst Frank Elstner nicht? Nee, hab ich noch nie gemocht. Du bist der einzige und erste Mensch, der Frank Elstner nicht mag? Das glaube ich nicht, ne? Ist das gerade so ein common Phänomen und du machst es nicht über mich lustig, weil alle den nicht mögen? Nein. Ich weiß es nicht, aber ich glaube, man kann nicht so viel an ihm nicht mögen. Ich glaube, es ist recht einfach, Frank Elstner aus dem Weg zu gehen.
Es ist ja wirklich nur schlimm bei Leuten, die man ständig sieht, dass man sie nicht mag.
Deswegen, wenn jemand sagt, ich mag keine Artischocken, sagt man, gut, dann bestell nicht die zwei Gerichte, auf denen Artischocken sind.
Es ist nicht schwer, denen aus dem Weg zu gehen, das ist kein Problem. Aber Frank Elstner ist keine Artischocke.
Frank Elstner ist sowas, auf das sich jeder einigen kann, aber wo man auch niemand sagt, da habe ich heute Abend Bock drauf. Deswegen, er ist so, sagen wir mal, so eine Petersilienkartoffel. Ja, okay. Die ist halt mal dabei und niemand sagt, ich hasse Petersilienkartoffeln, aber niemand sagt, weißt du, wo ich heute Abend Lust drauf habe? Petersilienkartoffel. Ja, Ich glaube, es gibt gewisse Dinge, wo man mal nachfragen müsste, mag das jemand? Weil ich glaube, gewisse Dinge werden einfach immer und immer wieder gemacht, weil man denkt, ja, irgendjemand wird das schon mögen, so Petersilie obendrauf. Das haben wir immer schon gemacht. Genau, und wo man denkt so, naja, ich mag es nicht, aber meine Gäste mögen es wahrscheinlich und man tut es drauf und die denken sich, ja gut, sie, die Gastgeberin mag das, aber vielleicht mag es einfach wirklich niemand. These, Remoulade. Oh. Und zwar auf Brötchen, wo man sie nicht erwartet, das explizit gesagt. Ja, genau. Ne, ne, ne, die heimliche Remoulade ist ein Dauder. Die Secret Remoulade, das meine ich wirklich ernst. Und ich glaube, die mag niemand, weil dann war ich hier bei einem lokalen Bäcker und den habe ich das jetzt schon erfolgreich ausgetrieben mit naserümpfenden Fragen, aber da ist keine Remunade drauf, oder? Und die dann immer so, na ja doch. Aber an der Reaktion der Verkäuferin in dem Fall habe ich schon gemerkt, ah okay, sie ist da auch gegen, gegen diese Firmenpolicy. Ja, und er hintere dir auch so, ja, ich mag das auch nicht so gern. Und dann die ganze Strasse, weg mit Remoulade. Can you hear the people sing, singing the songs of angry men? It is the music of the people who will not eat this shit again. Und so wurde die Remoulade abgeschafft. Gute Nacht. Wollen wir mal eine Lehmiserabel-Parodie machen, wo es darum geht, dass es gegen Remoulade geht? Le-Remoulade. Oder so eine Doku über so eine ganz unbedeutende Revolution. Da wurde nicht ein Diktator abgeschafft, sondern es wurde eingeführt, dass die Nutella-Gläser leicht breiter sind. Weil die waren normalerweise wie die Senfgläser, so hoch und dünn, aber die Leute haben keinen Bock, in Flaschenursprünglich, mit so einem ganz dünnen Flaschenhals, wo man immer so rein mit der Gabel musste, und das war schrecklich, scheusslich, bis die Leute auf die Straße gegangen sind und haben gesagt, jetzt reicht's. Wir hatten heute Morgen einen Termin zusammen, und deswegen habe ich dir schon davon erzählt, aber ich muss nochmal reflektieren, wir müssen es nochmal in aller Ausführlichkeit besprechen. Ich bin heute morgen zu dem Termin gekommen, du saßt bereits da und meine erste Frage war, hast du das Auto gesehen, was kein Rad hatte mit Berührung zum Boden, auf dem Bürgersteig stand, wie kam es dazu? Nee, also ich habe ja nur die Polizei gesehen. Du hast nur die Polizei gesehen. Ich bin lange gegangen und ich bin jemand, der sagt, oh, da ist ein Polizeiauto mit Blaulicht, ich bin kein Gaffer, ich gehe da nicht hin, ich mache keinen Umweg. Ich mache erst mal die Augen zu. Ich tue nicht so, als würde ich da jetzt zufällig vorbeigehen. Nein, ich versuche die Neugier zu unterdrücken und versuche weiterzugehen, weil ich weiß, dass die Leute da auch keinen Bock drauf haben. Wenn ich irgendwo mit dem Auto in den Baum fahren will, will ich, das Letzte, was ich will, ist, dass da 20 Leute mit ihren Schoko-Croissants drumrum stehen und mich angucken. Deswegen dachte ich mir, nein, überlass das schmierigen Leuten wie Stefan Tietze, die dir danach erzählen und Fotos gemacht haben und versuchst, darüber zu reden. Da war ich so kurz vor einem Foto. Aber auch weil die Situation war wieder entspannt. Also angenommen, es ist um neun Uhr passiert. Was ist passiert? Ein älterer Herr, der stand dann auch noch daneben rum. Allen Beteiligten, by the way, geht's gut. Das müsst ihr wissen für diese doch sehr actionreiche Geschichte. So, dann ist ein älterer Mann, der konnte kaum stehen mehr, sehr alt wirklich zum Gehstock in der Hand, hat wohl einfach, sagen wir wie es ist, das hat auch eine Anwohnerin mir gesagt, ich habe sehr viele Gespräche geführt, der hat wohl Bremse und Gas verwechselt. Es ist ein Alter, wo man ja auch sagen kann, sollte man in dem Alter nochmal eine Führerscheinprüfung machen müssen, sollte man da vielleicht irgendwie allgemein mal eine Nachprüfung, wie dem auch sein. Sollte man die Pedale nicht direkt nebeneinander machen? Aber weißt du was, wir machen es nicht politisch. Wir erzählen es einfach nur neutral. Er kam, er ist angefahren und hat es verwechselt, er hat das Lenkrad verrissen, ist dann über einen gesamten Fahrradständer gefahren, alle Fahrräder, da waren bestimmt 20 Fahrräder, platt, der ganze Fahrradständer aus diesen ...
Das war ein großes Tandem dann.
Es war ein riesen flaches Tandem. Für 20 Leute. Aus 20 Leuten. Die mussten alle zusammen nach Hause fahren. Aber man kennt das, dieser massive, aus dem auch so Poller gemacht sind, daraus so ein Fahrradständer, komplett platt gemäht. Und dann ist er auf einem von diesen grossen Alu-Metall- Mülleimer gelandet und das Auto stand quasi auf einem Bürgersteig, wo ich froh sein muss, dass das niemand mitgerissen hat, und schwebte dann wie so ein Denkmal auf diesem grossen Mülleimer, der auch platt war. Wahnsinn. Also, keiner der Reifen berührte den Boden, es sah wirklich wie aufgesetzt. Es sah für mich aus wie wenn ich mir ein Auto gecheatet habe bei GTA.
So, wenn es aus dem Himmel fällt. Und dann fällt es aber leider in das Haus. Ja, und dann glitscht es so ein bisschen. Es glitzcht rein und dann glitscht es so. So sah es ein bisschen aus. Und dass du da langgegangen bist und die Polizei gesehen hast, aber dieses Auto, was auf dem Bürgersteig fast in den Bäcker reingefahren ist, direkt da stand, in der Luft schwemmt, ist mir ein Rätsel, wie du das nicht sehen kannst. Ich habe demonstrativ weggeschaut. Ich wollte diesem alten Herren nicht noch die Scham ermöglichen, jetzt auch noch angegabbt zu werden von Jungspunden. Bei mir ist dann so ein bisschen der Journalismusinstinkt reingekickt. Sofort Interviews gemacht, sofort Kameras raus. Die Kamera rausgeholt und habe erstmal die Anwohner befragt, wie es sich gehört. Ich habe einen Kaffee geholt gegenüber.
Oder wie ein Rollenspieler eigentlich, du machst das eigentlich ganz gut, die auch irgendwo kommen und erstmal werden Leute gefragt. Wo sind die Quests? Ich gucke erstmal, was ich finde. Ich schaue mir mal das Auto genauer an. Würfel mal auf Wahrnehmung. Ich gehe erstmal in diese Bäckerei und nehme Dinge aus den Regalen, weil wenn man die rausnehmen kann, werden die schon was bedeuten. Ja. Ja.
Dann bin ich gegenüber in so eine Bäckerei gegangen und habe mir einen Kaffee bestellt
und habe dann die Verkäuferin in ein Gespräch unverfänglich verwickelt über den Vorfall. Und da kam heraus, nichts, niemand zu Schaden gekommen. Sie kannte den Mann, der wohnte da auch in der Nähe und so. Und das ist gerade passiert. Das kommt häufiger vor. Das ist schon ein paar Mal vor. Aber was war das denn für ein Auto, wenn es die Fahrräder platt gemacht hat?
Ja, eigentlich so eine normale, so eine alte E-Klasse, würde ich mal behaupten. Gut, das sagt mir gar nichts. Ich hatte das nicht mehr gedacht. Aber ich dicke das mal an. So eine Limousinenform. Ja, alte Leute in starken Autos, ist das ein wachsendes Problem? Weil ich meine, die Autos werden immer grösser, die Menschen werden immer älter. Aber wenn jemand grosse Autoerfahrung hat, im weitesten Sinne sind es doch die deutschen Omas und Opas, die haben doch grosse gefährliche Autoerfahrung im Zweiten Weltkrieg gesammelt. Ja, das stimmt schon ein bisschen. Es kann sein, dass da wirklich eine Welle, eine Stahlwelle auf uns zukommt, wo vielleicht in der Dokumentation im Jahre 2100 der Voice-Over sagen würde, die Menschen dachten, die grösste Gefahr sei der Klimawandel oder Kryptocurrencies, aber nein, die grösste Gefahr waren alte Menschen in grossen Autos. Und dann kommt eine 60-minütige Montage, wo Leute einfach in Bäckereien reinrasen. Wie glaubst du, wird das Fernsehen aussehen in 60 Jahren? Ich glaube, exakt so. Ich glaube, da ändert sich gar nichts. Ganz ehrlich? Es ändert sich enttäuschend wenig. Neulich habe ich die Tagesschau geschaut und dann wurde da ein Bauprojekt vorgeschlagen von einem Bahnhof, irgendwie in Frankfurt oder so soll ein neuer Bahnhofabschnitt gebaut werden. Soll komplett cool aus und so, aber halt auch wie ein Bahnhof, den man jetzt so antreffen könnte irgendwo. Und der soll fertiggestellt werden 2040, wo ich dachte, ne ne ne, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, 2040 soll die Welt anders aussehen. Der soll anders aussehen, keine Ecken, alles rund, schwebende Teile, Neonlichter. Und wir können doch nicht uns anmassen, jetzt schon für 2040 Projekte zu planen. Wer sind wir denn? 2040 fliegen wir doch durch die Lüfte und haben alle nur so floating hats mit so einem Aquarium, in so einem Kopf, so konserviert und fliegen so rum. Ja, stimmt ja nicht. Es gibt ja so Kirchen, die wurden in einer gewissen Epoche begonnen und dann ab dem zweiten Stock haben die Leute gesagt, das sieht scheiße aus, lass es mal in unserem Stil weiterbauen. Und dann kam die nächste Schicht in dem anderen und dann kam Gotik und dann kam die und oben ist dann irgendwie so eine Glaskuppel und dann irgendwie nochmal so ein Hologramm-Beyonce ganz oben drauf. Also wirklich eine Chimier an Bauer. Der Kölner Dom wurde ja 600 Jahre gebaut. Das ist unfassbar, dass die nicht irgendwann gesagt haben, weißt du was, das wird nicht mehr fertig,
fuck it, so, lassen wir es.
Ja, und oben einfach auch, dass sie das oben nicht mit Glas
fertiggestellt haben, ist auch ein Rätsel für mich.
Du kannst ja schlecht unten
anfangen, Gebäude muss man unten anfangen.
Ja. Altes Sprichwort,
Gebäude müssen von Fundament
hoch aufgebaut werden. Ja,
das ist das alte Sprichwort. Catchy.
Es ist schwierig, es ist wirklich schwierig.
Aber das stimmt, das haben die, aber eigentlich wie jede
Wohnung entsteht ein bisschen, ne?
Vielen Dank. hoch aufgebaut werden. Das ist also Sprichwort. Es ist schwierig, es ist wirklich schwierig.
Aber eigentlich wie jede Wohnung entsteht ein bisschen.
Man hat jetzt gerade einen Stil
und würde gerne seine Wohnung einrichten, wie auf diesem
Foto in der Schöner Wohnen oder
in der Architectural Digest
oder sowas, oder wie in dem
Internetfoto. Hat aber das Geld
nicht für die ganzen Möbelstücke,
also kauft man sich eins davon. Und dann, wenn man das Geld genug hat für das nächste Möbelstück aus diesem Foto, so hat aber das Geld nicht für die ganzen Möbelstücke, also kauft man sich eins davon, so und dann, wenn man das Geld genug hat für das nächste Möbelstück aus diesem Foto, gefällt einem aber dieser Stil nicht mehr, man kauft es für was anderes. Also eigentlich ist es ja so ein bisschen so, man hat, wenn man nicht alles auf einmal machen kann, wird es auch in der Regel nicht so richtig durchdacht geil. Aber ist das nicht der Grund, warum sich Minimalismus durchgesetzt hat als Designgrundstimmung, weil man gesagt hat, wir wissen eh nicht, was es wird, lass uns einfach leere Räume machen, mit Weiss vielleicht. Ich meine, Weiss ist nie aus der Mode. Türkis, Weiss bleibt erstmal da. Leute haben sich auf Weiss committed die letzten Jahre. Das passt schon, das wird schon. Ist okay. Und dann einfach so ein Kleiderbügel in der Mitte des Raumes vielleicht. Aber so ein neutraler Bügel. Ja, so ganz neutral. Eichenholz. Ganz locker. Was ist das normalste Holz? Eichenholz. Eichen, irgendwas, nimm irgendwas, nimm Luft, nimm Eis, nimm wirklich Dinge, die sich nicht verändern werden. Ja, ich glaube auch. Aber du sagst, Minimalismus ist vorbei, es geht wieder vorwärts. Das war eine kurze Atempause in der Geschichte der Menschheit.
Aber das Gute ist, wenn Minimalismus vorbei ist, man hat die Wohnung nicht zugestellt mit Müll.
Das stimmt.
Man kann dann relativ schnell seine neue Identität drüber stülpen.
Ja, finde ich passend.
Das ist auch immer so geil, wenn man zum Beispiel, es ist mir zum Beispiel aufgefallen, jetzt für die Serie,
eine dritte Staffel, Tom Brauch ist rausgekommen, Florentin ist auf dem Poster. Yes! Ganz rechts unten. Falls ihr es sucht, ganz rechts unten. Und falls ihr es jetzt immer noch sucht, scrollt mal rein. Aber da ist er. Ja, ich hoffe, ihr habt einen Hochauf-Lösin-Monitor, sonst wird das nichts. Auf einem waschechten Poster. Und da dachte ich mir zum ersten Mal, als man dann so die Zimmer eingerichtet gesehen hat, warum sehen Zimmer nicht so aus von echten Teenagern? Und dann fällt nämlich auf, und das haben wir dann auch gemacht, Teenager-Kinderzimmer sind niemals nur aus der Zeit. Kinderzimmer sind nämlich wie Identitäten, denen neue Identitäten übergestülpt werden. Das heißt, du hast durchaus noch die Was-ist-was-Bücher im Regal. Ja. Auch wenn du 16 Jahre alt bist, die schmeißt du ja dann noch nicht weg, die schmeißt du irgendwann mal weg. Du hast auch noch irgendwo den Lego Millennium Falcon drin stehen. Genau, du hast auch noch eine dumme Bettdecke. Du hast auch noch eine dusselige Bettdecke. So wo du einfach weißt, das wird nichts, mit der Bettdecke, das wird nichts. Du hast auch noch die Snoopy-Bettdecke. Ja, oder vielleicht so eine, wie heißt es, so eine Bordüre an der Wand hat man früher gehabt, an Tapeten. Kennst du das Wort Bordüre? Keine Ahnung, sagt mir gar nicht. Ich finde, so heißt die Folge dann auch, so wie du dann die Folge mittlerweile benennst. Nee, am Rand hast du dann so eine Snoopy-Tapeten-Ecke hast. Ach so, du meinst so einen Tapetenstreifen. So einen Tapetenstreifen. Wir haben Bordüre gesagt. In meinem Haushalt haben wir Wagner gehört und Bordüre. Okay. Ja, das stimmt. Dann hast du auch mal als Kind irgendwas drangemalt, so Tage bis Weihnachten oder so, und das macht man ja nicht weg. So, das ist alles noch da. Nee, das geht auch sprichwärlich nicht weg. Ja, das stimmt schon. Das ist eigentlich ein guter Punkt, weil du kriegst ja kein Kind mit 16. Das fängt ja nicht mit 16 an. Es hat ja schon ein ganzes Leben gelebt bis dahin in dem Raum.
Ja, und als Teenager bist du selten in dem Modus und sagst, das ganze Zimmer braucht ein totales Makeover. Ich baue jetzt alles um, das würdest du nicht machen. Ja, ich weiß noch, als ich damals mein Hochbett rausgeschmissen habe aus meinem Zimmer, als ich gesagt habe, ich bin jetzt kein Kind mehr, ich habe jetzt Geschlechtsverkehr, da kann ich kein Hochbett haben. So, wie ich bis heute nicht benutze, soll das gehen? Und ja, nach zwei Jahren habe ich es wieder reingeholt und dachte mir, ein Hochbett ist schon cool einfach so. Das lohnt sich nicht. Cooler als Sex, glaube ich, weil es nicht passiert. Aber das war so der Moment, wo ich wirklich gesagt habe, nee, jetzt ist meine Kindheit vorbei. Weiß ich noch, da lag ich im Hochbett und dachte, das ist eigentlich Quatsch, ich bin eigentlich zu alt dafür. Wie soll das funktionieren? Man macht sich dann ganz konkret Gedanken so, rein theoretisch, angenommen, man würde mal eine junge Dame nach Hause einladen und du hast ein Hochbett, das gross genug ist für eine Person. Was passiert dann? Sagt man, du kannst auf meinem Snoopy-Sofa schlafen? Schwierig, ganz kompliziert, da stellen sich unangenehm Fragen und dann geht plötzlich der Prozess los des Erwachsenwerdens. Ich habe auch das Problem gehabt, dass ich nicht in diesem typischen Elternhaus aufgewachsen bin, was so modern war, dass es diese amerikanische Architektur hatte. Mit Wohnzimmer unten, Elternschlafzimmer vielleicht sogar unten und viele Freunde von mir haben im ersten Stock irgendwo gewohnt und hatten da einigermaßen ihre Ruhe oder so.
Nein, mein Zimmer war direkt neben dem Elternschlafzimmer und ganz klein.
Und deswegen, also gegliche Gedanken an, ich lade mal ein Mädchen zu mir ein und man hat da Geschlechtsverkehr, sind nie aufgekommen, weil es die Architektur schlecht nicht zugelassen hat.
Ja, das stimmt.
Also es ist ein Architekturproblem.
Also meine verkorkste Lugend ist ein architektonisches Problem. Ja, das stimmt. Die verdammten Architekten, die wissen gar nicht, wie viel Macht sie haben. Nee, und kein anderes Zimmer war als Kinderzimmer geeignet. Es war also von den Anschlüssen her und den Steckdosen war das das Kinderzimmer. Da hing auch schon so kleine, so ein Dekor von der Decke, irgendwie so eine Lampe, die rotiert. Das war einfach vorausgedacht. Der Einbauschrank, das war Kinderzimmer, das war klar. Da war nicht dran zu rütteln. Aber an Geschlechtsverkehr war in diesem Zimmer nicht zu denken. Interessant, da bin ich mal in den Keller gezogen. Ich war auch im Keller, ich war lange im Keller. Keller war dann die nächste Phase, so das fand ich auch mal ganz gut. Dich einen eigenen Ausgang und Eingang, weil meine Eltern wussten, dass ich nicht spät auf Partys gehe oder so, einfach egal. Ja. Aber das war eine gute Zeit, bis dann irgendwie es Jahrhundertregen kam und mein Kellerzimmer voller Wasser geflossen ist. Aber das war sehr traumatisch. War ein cooler Abend. Aber ist schon cool, wenn sowas passiert, oder? Ist schon richtig cool. Ich denke da regelmäßig dran. Mit einem wohligen Grinsen? Mit einem wohligen Grinsen und vor allem auch mein guter Freund der Popcorn-Eimer. Immer die Aldi-Wochen, die Amerika-Aldi-Wochen, der Highlight meines Jahres, meines Kinderjahres, weil da gab es dieses geile Popcorn im Eimer. Bei anderen waren Kinderwänden immer Tage bis Weihnachten, bei dir war Tage bis Amerika-Wochen. Weil da gab es sowohl die Jellybeans, als auch Popcorn, als auch die Spare-Ribs, als auch die Pancakes und die Pancake-Mischung. Also Pancakes für jetzt, fertig kaufen und dann die Mischung für die Zukunft. Ich habe ein ganzes Jahr gespart, nur auf die Amerika-Wochen. Und dann kam ich schon immer an und habe versucht, mit meinen kleinen Kinderhänden so möglichst viele Popcorn-Eimer zu tragen und stellt sich raus, die haben das Leben gerettet.
Mit diesem Eimer konnte ich dann meinen Keller aus eimern.
Du hast Captain Jack Sparrow artig. Hast du den Eimer genommen und wie er mit dem Boot?
Draußen war so eine Art Schacht, wo dann das Wasser reingeflossen und es entstand dann auch 20 Zentimeter über dem unteren Ende meines Fensters und kam dann irgendwann rein und musste sich raus den Regen und das ausschaufeln. Aber es hat Spaß gemacht. Wo du gerade gesagt hast, draußen war da ein Schacht und dann ist mir aufgefallen, dass ich nie verstehe, wenn Leute mir Orte erklären. Null. Keine Chance. Ich habe mir auch gerade gedacht, ich dachte, ich mache die Erklärung kurz, damit es schnell weitergeht, weil die Leute machen sich doch auch keine Mühe, das vorzustellen. Aber ich dachte immer, das wäre ein Problem, das ich habe, weil wenn Leute immer Orte erklären, immer, ja, ich habe in so einem Elternhaus gewohnt, da war hinten so eine Ecke und da war dann so ein Verschlag. Also direkt ober der Bordüre war dann noch so der Giebel und der führte dann direkt in den Verschlag und dann war hinten noch so eine Ecke. Ins Maisonnet und du so einfach Fragezeichen, ein Land voller Fragezeichen. Aber ich sehe mich häufig in Räumen, wo irgendwas erklärt wird und ich stehe daneben und verstehe nicht, ich habe keine Vorstellung von... Ne, auch so Ortsbeschreibung, wo ist denn hier die Apotheke? Da gehst du runter, die Strasse runter, über der Kreuzung links und dann direkt an der Hecke und denkst dir, ich habe aufgehört. Ich habe von der ersten Sekunde was verstanden. Ich habe aufgepasst, dass ich mich nicht verspreche beim Stellen der Frage, dann war das raus und okay. Ja, keine Chance, noch nie mitbekommen. Und das geht mir aber häufig auch so bei Vorstellungsrunden, wenn Leute sich vorstellen. Meistens vergesse ich den Namen sofort, ich merke mir den gar nicht. Ja, man müsste eigentlich etablieren, dass man mindestens drei bis fünf Mal den Namen sagt. Also das ist ganz normal. Ab sieben ist doch ins Kurzeiggedächtnis. Wie heisst du? Ich heisse Miriam, Miriam, Miriam, Miriam, Miriam und ich heisse Paul, Paul, Paul, Paul und alle zusammen Paul. Selbst dann, glaube ich, würde mir die Hälfte ankommen, aber zumindest mal die Hälfte. Die Regel ist ab sieben. Ab sieben geht's ins Kurzzeitgedächtnis. Ja, genau. Lass uns doch sieben sagen. Lass uns jetzt einfach mal eine Zahl festlegen und lass uns mal sieben sagen. Wenn wir merken, das ist einfach zu viel, können wir ja nächste Woche wieder ein bisschen runter korrigieren. Pendel, wir machen das Pendel. Wir machen das Pendel, aber wir lassen es einfach mal ausschlagen. Hi, ich bin Stefan. Stefan. Stefan. Stefan. Das ist viel zu viel. Stefan. Sieben ist viel zu viel. Stefan. Ich habe jetzt erst sechs. Stefan. Nee, sieben ist zu viel. Vier. Hi, ich heiße Florentin. Florentin. Florentin. Florentin. Und ich wollte mal fragen, wo die Apotheke ist.
Ja, finde ich super. Die ist da hinten rechts. Hinten rechts. Wenn sie hier rinden und dann rechts. Hinten rechts. Okay, danke. Ich glaube, es funktioniert. Ich glaube, die Gesellschaft würde insgesamt besser funktionieren, wenn man das einfach so durchsetzen würde. Ich finde das supergut. Ja, finde ich auch. Also, mir hat mal eine Freundin erzählt, die hat sich in der Uni angefangen und war so in der ersten Woche, wo man sich vorgestellt hat und ihm das tolle Spiel gespielt, dass sie sich immer ein Adjektiv geben musste. Und ehrlich gesagt, es hilft schon. Ja, es hilft schon, aber es ist auch ein bisschen albern, ab einem gewissen Punkt. Ich meine, wenn du so, vor allem das Problem ist. Ich bin der Störenfried Stefan. Ja, also kommt, okay, kommt darauf an, wie groß die Gruppe ist.
Aber es gibt diesen, ich sag mal, den La-Ola-Effekt, nenn ich ihn mal, dass wenn so eine grosse Gruppe Reihe umgeht, man ab einem gewissen Punkt nicht mehr zuhört, sondern rechnet, wie viele sind es noch bis mir, wie viele Leute, okay, es sind jetzt 20 Leute. Statistisch gesehen haben drei von denen den Vornamen. Genau, sagen wir mal zwei haben noch F. Sagen wir mal irgendwie so ein Fabian und eine Flora. Foul brauche ich gar nicht nehmen. Foul vergiss es, Frech ist weg. Ist weit außer Reichweite. Frech ist das erste, was genannt wurde. Ich träume von Frech. Träume nicht mal davon. Fett, ja, ist das so eine selbstironische Runde? fetter, weiß ich nicht, friss, frivol, fressgierig, frivol, fisch, scheiße, und dann bist du dran, keine Ahnung. Und sagt dann ausserdecken trotzdem fett. Und niemand lacht. Ja, Alter. Stimmt doch gar nicht. Nee, ich finde nicht, dass du fett bist. Rebecca. Ich bin die Reudige Rebecca. Es ist furchtbar. Genauso wie in Latein, wenn die Aufgabe ist und es geht Reih um und du schon auf dein Wort vorrechnest und du denkst, vergiss es, audete, forget it. Und dann die ganze Zeit nur audete, audete. Und ich hoffe, dass vorher der Fehler gemacht wurde und man gar nicht erst drankommt. Aber in all diesen, nennt man ja diese Icebreaking-Spiele, habe ich immer das Gefühl, ich achte nicht auf das, was gerade das Icebreaking sollte. Bei mir wächst im Gegensatz so eine harte Schicht Permafrost noch drüber, weil ich die ganze Zeit angestrengt darüber nachdenke, wie kann ich möglichst cool von allen geliebt werden. Mental stehe ich backstage, höre das Publikum schon draußen, laufe nervös auf und ab, habe noch einen Zettel in der Hand, wo mein Text draufsteht, der von meinem Schweiss mittlerweile schon fast unleserlich verschmiert wurde und ich auch scheiße, fette, fette, Flo, Floren, Florentin, Florentin, Florentin, Flo, ah fuck, scheiße, kann es nicht.
Und draußen, du hörst das Publikum lachen, warum lachen die, was, warum lachen die?
Die röhnige Rebecca hat einen Gag gemacht.
Scheiße, fuck, oh Gott, Florentin.
Ja, und auch hoffen, dass die Leute vor einem nicht deliveren.
Ja, absolut.
Denkt man sich, soll ich mal husten?
Soll ich mal mit dem Gag reinhusten?
Also, ich bin die röhnige Rebecca Rebecca. Rönige Rebecca. Okay, danke. Gemein. Man muss gucken, wie man überlebt. Fressen oder gefressen werden. Jeder von diesen Gruppenorganisationsspielen ist Krieg. Das ist das Nächste, was wir haben am Krieg. Wer ist denn da drin, er selbst, man selbst, sie selbst? Wann ist man jemals mein Selbst? Ich glaube, vielleicht gibt es Leute, die sind nur da sie selbst, die da aufblühen, die wirklich da ihren Moment haben, die sich schon die ganze Woche freuen auf die Fortbildung, auf dem Moment, wo irgendwie lustig man irgendwie seinen Schuh irgendwo hinstellen muss, wie man mit den anderen in Beziehung steht oder so ein Quatsch und die dann einfach immer die richtige Antwort drauf haben und genau wissen, was los ist. Ich überlege, wann bin ich ich selbst und ich will selbst eigentlich, wenn ich alleine bin, cool sein von mir. Kennst du das, wenn du dich versprichst im Auto beim Fluchen? Ja, und du kommst noch mal rein? Ich komme noch mal rein. Man parkt das Auto noch mal, steigt noch mal ein und sagt, so, jetzt aber losfahren. Nee, ich wiederhole die Beschimpfung in richtiger Grammatik dann. Ja? Ja. Kennt man ja, wenn man manchmal sagt, du blöder Arschloch und dann, fuck ja, sorry, sorry, ich komme noch mal, Entschuldigung, du blödes Arschloch. Kennst du das nicht, das passiert mir häufig, dass ich alleine irgendwie fluche, verspreche ich mich doof,
und ergere ich mich noch mehr über mich selbst.
Wer ist hier das Arschloch? Ich bin das Arschloch!
Ich bin so unsicher, ich bin nicht mal vor mir selbst.
Echt.
Du hast halt hohe Ansprüche an dich.
Aber du bist ja zumindest der, der korrigiert, der beeindruckt werden solltest.
Du bist ja zumindest anwesend, du bist zumindest dabei. Ich bin im Prozess befeiligt. Du stehst nicht auf der Bühne, aber du sitzt zumindest im Publikum. Das ist doch schon mal was. Du hast die Zeit gefunden, überhaupt zu kommen. Das ist besser als bei vielen anderen, die im Stau stehen oder so. Da habe ich auch gedacht, wenn irgendwann mal der Vorwurf kommt, so vor demjenigen bist du ganz anders, denke ich mir so, nee, das prallt an mir ab, dieser Vorwurf. Selbst vor mir bin ich so, wie ich dann in dem Moment sein möchte. Vielleicht sagst du das irgendwann zu dir selber. Sag mal, Stefan, du bist echt, vor mir bist du ganz anders. Und dann hast du ein echtes Problem. Dann kommst du da nicht mehr raus. Ich habe gestern eine Motte gejagt bei mir in der Wohnung. Wie lange hat das gedauert? Eine riesige Motte. Wie lange war die Verfolgungsjagd? Zwanzig Minuten. Zwanzig Minuten? Zwanzig Minuten? Ich bin davon aufgewacht. Aber Motte sind doch total langsam. Die kann ein alter Zauberer in der offenen Hand fangen. Nein. Ein alter Zauberer, da gebe ich dir recht. Aber ein alter Mensch nicht. Okay. Aber die war so, ich bin aufgewacht von ... Und man baut das dann noch so ein bisschen in den Traum ein. Kennst du das? Dieses Gefühl, das kommt dann im Traum, kommt das Geräusch von. Und immer, der man so, ich bin komplett wahnsinnig, das ist nicht im Traum, das ist mit Applaus. Bei dir wird alles in Applaus umgemünzt. Der Feueralarm und bei dir ... So eine sehr grosse Motte. Grosste Publikum. Da bin ich wach geworden und habe gemerkt, das ist eine riesen Motte in der Ecke meines Raumes. Und da bin ich mit so einem Badelatschen herumgelaufen. Das ist deine Waffe, deine Go-To-Waffe, die du unterm Bett, unterm Kopfkissen hast. Wo unten schon so ein paar Botten drankleben. Wie auch am Anfang, wenn die noch so halbtot sagen, lauf, flieh. Nee, denen hängen so Motten seid gewarnt Schilder um. Oh ja, genau. Weißt du, versteht ihr die Referenz? Ich verstehe alles. Ich glaube, wenn jemand die Referenz versteht, dann du. Und dann weiß ich nicht mehr, worauf ich hinaus sollte. Aber ich habe die jedenfalls gejagt.
Und hast du sie erwischt?
Wann haben wir die Thema?
Hast du sie erwischt?
Träume?
Nee, davor kamen wir von einem anderen Thema.
Es klang für mich wie ein ziemlich harter Kapp, ehrlich gesagt, ein Motten-Thema.
Ich war eigentlich stolz auf den Übergang.
Genau, und da habe ich am Ende geflucht über diese Motte, bin länger gelaufen, und mir sind richtig coole Beleidigungen eingefallen.
Ich war irgendwie stolz auf mich und dachte mir, obwohl ich alleine bin, wem würde ich jetzt da gefallen in der Situation der Motte? Warum rede ich überhaupt laut darüber fluchen, dass ich jetzt diese Motte jahre? So, aber jetzt musst du mal blankziehen. Deine Top-3-Motten-Beleidigungen. Weiß nicht mehr. Ich habe jedenfalls auch, nachts hat man auch diese geile Stimme, man denkt, ich fand mich irgendwie cool. Du hast diese coole Spitzmütze auf, du hast die Kerze in der Hand. Nie nirgends ist man cooler, als wenn man nachts aufgeweckt wird. Ich bin cool gewesen. Dicker Pyjama, so ein altes Schlafschirm. So ein G-Stock. Schlafschirm, eine XXXL. Ja, mit Löchern drin und von Motten. Dann habe ich sie erwischt und dann ist sie, wie alle Motten, komplett zu Staub zerfallen. Wie sie sich zu Staub zerfallen. Wenn man Motten tötet, und das mache ich jetzt nicht regelmäßig, aber wenn man Motten tötet, dann hat man doch selten Körper. Du weißt, wie so ein Vampir, der dann so da liegt und dann sich so in Staub fützt. Ja, wie Avengers Endgame. Ja. Wo die Leute dann dann so Staub zerfallen. Wir sagen nicht welche. Ist kein Spoiler, aber wir sagen nicht welche. Die Hälfte. Aber wir sagen nicht welche Hälfte. Ist schon ein konkreter Spoiler. Nachnamen A bis L. Aber wir sagen nicht welche davon. Aber die sind und das fällt einem doch wirklich auf. Ich habe auch noch nie eine Mottenleiche gesehen. Wenn du Fliegen kaputt machst, hast du danach einen fliegen, einen prallen geöffneten Fliegenkörper, der dich vorwurfsvoll anschaut, an deiner Waffe hängen. Wenn du eine Motte kaputt machst, feiner Staub. Das sind wie so zwielichtige Nachtgeschöpfe, die so zu uns geschickt wurden von der Anderswelt. Aber entstehen die auch aus Staub? Also kommen dann da wieder Staub raus? Ja. Motten raus? Ja, wie ein Phönix. Da fliegen die wieder los. Hatten wir Baby-Motten gesehen? Nein. Nein, nein. Die stehen aus dem Staub. Oder weiss jemand, wo Staub herkommt? Vielleicht sind es alles tote Motten. Tote Motten. Ich habe heute, weil ich packe gerade für meinen Urlaub. Du bist ein Langpacker? Es gibt gewisse Gegenstände, die benutze ich einmal im Jahr. Für meinen Urlaub einmal im Jahr. Meinen Gameboy zum Beispiel. Den rühre ich nur an für den Urlaub. Insektenspray. Das heißt, wenn ich vom Urlaub nach Hause komme, lege ich den Gameboy in den Schrank, lasse ihn dort für ein Jahr Sommer, Winter,
Ziemlich genau bei dir auch, ne? Einmal exakt ein Jahr, komme dann wieder und habe eine Staubschicht, die exakt ein Jahr, ein Jahr ist.
Das heißt, ich kann immer genau da messen, ein Jahr, und ich sage dir eins, dieses Jahr ziemlich wenig Staub,
ziemlich weniger Staub als sonst.
Ich weiß nicht, was, also ich will nur mal ganz kurz sagen, die Meteorologen mal vorwarnen.
Ich weiß nicht, wer dein Auge drauf hat, aber ich habe das Gefühl, dass es dieses Jahr sehr wenig Staub gab in meiner Wohnung.
Vielleicht weil es allgemein windiger wurde in einer Wohnung.
Möglich, kann möglich sein.
Rein und raus.
Ja, vielleicht aber auch weniger Motten-Tode, vielleicht lebe ich friedlicher mit Motten oder die haben abgezogen ihre Truppen. Ich weiß es nicht genau. Weniger Teppiche? Aber musst du dich beantworten, wenn es zu privat ist. Nein, nein, die Teppichzahl hat sich tatsächlich von null auf null nicht verändert. Also von daher kann es daran nicht liegen. Aber ist es nicht auch so erstaunlich für dich, wie gleichmäßig Staub sich auf die gesamte Wohnung wie so ein Dach setzt? Ja, das ist merkwürdig. Weil das ist doch nichts so gleichmäßig. Weil wenn man sich die Wüste mal anschaut, auch da gibt es Berge. Also da gibt es ja irgendwo mehr Staub als an anderen Orten. Wo kommt denn Staub her? Warum gibt es nicht im Wohnungsstaub nicht auch solche Dünen, sagt man ja? Oh, ich hatte Dünen neulich, hatte ich Dünen. Ja? Ja, ja. Da kam, aber da war... Schön auf dem Buch. Dünenkatalysator Pollen. Ich habe so einen Durchzug bei mir in der Wohnung gemacht und habe an beiden Seiten so krasse Bäume mit so Pollen-Alert. Ja. Und die sind dann reingekommen und haben sich dann so, wie so Tumbleweed in meiner Wohnung, haben sich dann so... Wir werden Bäume! Ja. Nee. Ich glaube glaube nicht. Da ist mir auch noch mal klar geworden, dass ich Pollen nicht verstehe. Weil Pollen ist ja auch nicht, ist auch richtig falsch, das Wort, was ich benutze, oder was wir hinlänglich benutzen, wenn man diese weissen, durchgängigen Staubknäuel durch die Stadt fliegen sieht. Sind das Pollen oder sind das nicht einfach, das ist Baumsamen? Du, da triffst du mich jetzt unvorbereitet.
Pollen sieht man ja eigentlich nicht, glaube ich. Ich weiß nicht, es kommt darauf an, manchmal so in der Sonne, schimmerig, glaube ich, kann man die manchmal schon sehen. Ich habe mich mit einem Freund ganz doll gestritten, weil ich dachte die ganze Zeit, dass Alleininsekten für die Bestäubung und damit die Fortpflanzung von Pflanzen verantwortlich sind. Und dann hat er behauptet, nein, oder halt
Pollen. Bäume
zum Beispiel schicken Pollen
und die landen dann
auf den zu befruchtenden anderen
Gegenparts. Nein.
Und die schicken nichts zurück.
Die geben nichts zurück.
Die schicken ja auch was ab.
Aber Bäume können sich, und das halte ich
fest, es stimmt, ich habe es für Google danach,
ich konnte es nicht glauben, Bäume können sich
gegenseitig befruchten, weil die halt so eine
Aber Die schicken ja auch was ab. Aber Bäume können sich, und das halte ich fest, es stimmt, ich habe es für Google danach, konnte es nicht glauben, Bäume können sich gegenseitig befruchten, weil die halt so eine Wand, und ich dachte mir, ja genau, und diese eine Eiche in Köln, die findet genau die andere Eiche und bläst dann dahin, ja, die Antwort ist ja. Aber du hast manche Bäume, die schicken einfach eine Horde, so eine Wand aus Pollen, die siehst du nicht, ist einfach wie so ein Luftstrom in Richtung und dann mit dem Wind muss es dann genau auch einen anderen Baum treffen.
Und dann trifft es genau da rein, wo das dann sich befruchtet und dann kommen Samen. Aber hat die nicht auch die neue Eiche da erst hingepflanzt? Weil die Pollen müssen sich ja in der gleichen Richtung bewegen wie die Samen. Im Grunde ist es Inzest, weil du notwendigerweise deine Kinder befruchtest, weil das zieht ja immer in Windrichtung weiter dann eigentlich. Und dann schön Opa mit Papa, Papa mit, also jetzt in Baum Generationen gesprochen, gehst du ja den Stammbaum immer einen Ast runter und da wird ordentlich befruchtet. Also jeder Sprosse ist ein ordentlicher Befruchtungsakt. Ja, vielleicht. Aber wie geht es in die andere Richtung? Aber finde ich kein schönes Bild, weil diese Blümchen und Bienchen, da hat ja jeder was davon. Die Biene kriegt den Nektar und die Blume hat einen schönen Arm, sagen wir es mal so. Nee, und da würde ich auch als Biene irgendwann so sagen, ja, dann bin ich hier raus. Gut, wenn ihr mich nicht braucht. So, ich würde noch kurz meinen Honig nehmen, aber ich brauche jetzt nicht irgendwie hier groß noch für die Welt sorgen. Ihr kommt ja auch ganz gut alleine, ich war eifersüchtig, ihr kommt ja gut alleine, klar. Ja, es ist ja ein schönes Bild, weil beide was davon haben, wohingegen bei Bäumen ist es ja eher eine sehr einseitige Beziehung, muss man sagen. Ja. Weil der Wind dreht ja nur in eine Richtung, das heißt der Empfänger gibt ja nie was an den Sender. Fehlschluss, der Wind geht nicht nur in eine Richtung. Was? Aha. Der Wind dreht sich ja kontinuierlich. Kontinuierlich? Ja, bei der Aussage bleibe ich. Weil die Erde sich dreht oder was? Nein, der Wind dreht sich kontinuierlich. Kontinuierlich? Ja, bei der Aussage bleibe ich.
Weil die Erde sich dreht oder was?
Nein, der Wind dreht sich kontinuierlich.
Warum?
Was sind das für Faktoren, die die Windrichtung beeinflussen?
Wetter, was Wetter.
Ja, was Wetter?
Ich kann ja einfach Wetter sagen.
Wetter ist das Äquivalent von tektonischen Platten.
Hoch- und Tiefdruckgebiete drehen sich ja anders, entgegengesetzt und so.
Und je nachdem, ob man von rechts ein Hochdruck, von links ein Tiefdruckgebiet kommt. Aber es gibt doch schon Tendenzen, oder? Ich würde auch sagen, ja, aber ich glaube, dass der Wind sich schon ein gemein eher recht gleichmäßig dreht hier im Rheinland. Sehr weit zurückgerudert. Natürlich. Wird es überhaupt eher aus einer Richtung? Aber gleicht sich der Wind auf der gesamten Erde gegenseitig wieder aus. Gibt es genauso viel Wind nach rechts wie nach links? Wenn du jetzt mal alle Winde auf der Erde auf eine Liste schreibst, kommt es wieder bei null raus? Und jetzt, glaube ich, spielt die Erdumdrehung dann doch eine Rolle. Aber da möchte ich mich nicht... Wen können wir dazu jetzt anrufen? Philipp Hauptmann ist da auch raus, ne? Ich glaube, alles ausserhalb der Atmosphäre ist. Der ist Astrophysiker. Ich glaube, alles ausserhalb der Atmosphäre ist sehr gut bedient. Jedenfalls, wir haben ein Update zu unserer Expertenliste. Denn Investigativ-Thais, Investi-Thais ... Wir haben sie von alleine gelassen. Hat geantwortet mal wieder auf eine Nachricht von uns. Ehrlich gesagt, ich will, dass sie raus ist und uns blockiert. Ich dachte, sie ist zu cool für uns. Ich dachte wirklich, sie hat uns überlebt und ist zu cool für uns. Wie das Snoopy Bordelair, das man nicht mehr anguckt. Bordüre. Bordüre. Dass man noch so mit Rumhängen hat, aber eigentlich bei der nächsten Gelegenheit rausschmeißt. So dachten wir, sind wir für Thais. Aber nein, sie hat die investigativen Journalismus-Zähne gefletscht und ist jetzt auf der Jagd. Also falls ihr was zu verbergen habt, dann versteckt euch verdammt nochmal, bevor sie euch aus eurem Drecks-Lügenloch zieht. Es fängt an bei unserem Whistleblower von Dominos. Ansonsten geben wir keine weiteren Informationen. Wir wollen nicht, dass Dominos jetzt unseren Schlachtplan erfährt und die sich verstecken. Und wir wollen auch auf gar keinen Fall, dass die Anwälte scharf machen. Nee, wir wollen nicht, dass wenn wir anrufen, die unter dem Schreibtisch sind und sich verstecken. Und wir sagen, wir sehen sie doch. Wir wissen genau, dass sie hier sind. Gut, dann kommen wir morgen wieder. Ja. Wir brauchen auch einen Anwalt übrigens, weil ich habe echt Angst ein bisschen, dass das in einem Eklat endet, Eklär endet. Ich habe die Angst, seitdem ich Hunger habe, seit ein paar Stunden habe ich wirklich Angst, dass das Ganze im Eklär endet. Ich glaube, das könnte ganz ... Die Frage ist halt, inwiefern hilft uns ein Anwalt?
Wir haben hier einen Riesen-Eclair. Sorry, wir brauchen hier unbedingt Unterstützung.
Es kann passieren, es kann wirklich passieren. Aber wir wollen euch nicht weiter auf keine strategischen Vorteile geben, denn Thais muss, glaube ich, auch aus dem Schatten kommen.
Aus hinter einer Ecke, wenn ihr es gar nicht erwartet, und wir sprechen jetzt auch niemanden von euch Hörern speziell an, aber ihr dürft nicht erwarten, eines Tages, ihr geht nach Hause, ihr steigt aus dem Auto, hat ein Sixpack unterm Arm, macht noch mit eurem rechten Daumen so ein Bup Bup das Auto zu, ihr dreht euch um, wollt zur Wohnung gehen und BAM, da ist sie. Block gezückt, Feder im Hut und fragt euch mal so fucking investigativ aus, dass ihr nicht zurückhalten könnt. Ja, mit so einer Pfeife im Mund.
Ja.
Die sitzt ihr dann da auf dem Sofa.
Im Halbdummel.
Genau, im Haus.
Genau, man macht das Licht an und sie nur, Überraschung.
Überraschung.
Und klick, klick.
Ta-da, ta-da.
Na, wenn das kein Eclair wird. Und dann sitzt sie da und macht da raus ein Investigativ. Ich will eine, also Thais, die hört den Podcast nicht mehr. Aber ich möchte gerne einen investigativen Beitrag mit Schatten, Schattenwand, verfremdeter Stimme. Eine Audio-Schattenwand, ja. Mindestens einen, dem wir entweder eine verbrühtete Stimme drauflegen, weil wir es wollen oder weil er es selber will. Wir würden Sie jetzt gerne interviewen. Könnten Sie vielleicht, weil es ist ja schon ein ziemlich brisantes Thema, könnten Sie vielleicht Ihre Stimme leicht verstellen? Klar! Gut. Klar, klar! Also, wegen den Vorwürfen, die gegen Ihre Firma erhoben werden, der Umweltverschmutzung ... Stimme Sache!
Ja, aber haben Sie dazu nichts zu sagen? Sie haben doch vor zwei Jahren noch eine Pressemitteilung rausgegeben, dass Sie komplett unschuldig sind und die Lieferketten überprüft werden, jeden Monat.
Ja, ich bleibe auch bei der Aussage. Ich bitte bei der Aussage bleiben.
Wir haben hier die Akten gefunden, in Ihrem eigenen Archiv!
Das ist verrat! Raus!
Sie können es nicht rausschmeissen! Sie verlassen sofort mein Büro! Aber wir kommen wieder. Die Stimme des Interviewpartners wurde für dieses Interview verfremdet. Von ihm selbst verfremdet. Nach unserem Wunsch von ihm selbst verfremdet. Raus! Warum ist Mickey Mouse so erfolgreich? Ich habe niemanden vergewaltigt! Das ist ein bisschen Mickey Mouse, ne? Es ist Mickey Mouse, aber hat jemand mal verstanden, warum Mickey Mouse beliebt ist? Weil Donald ist lustig, Pluto ist süss, Mickey Mouse... Okay, Mary, fuck, kill Mickey, Mickey, goofy, Donald. Aber ich glaube, das Nächste ist leichter. Kill, Mickey, fuck, Donald und Mary, Pluto. Aber sofort. Nee, mein Goofy. Warum hast du Pluto in den Mix geworden? Ich habe Donald. Pluto? Du hast Pluto in den Mix geworden. Ach so, du bist jetzt im DC. Du bist jetzt im DC, nicht Marvel. Okay, ich glaube, Donald ist Marvel.
DC sind die langweiligen.
DC sind Mickey Mouse, Pluto und Goofy.
Aber sind Marvel und DC nicht einfach Verläge?
Also ist das Deutsche, ist Kiwi oder Fischer im Deutschen DC?
DC heißt ja Detective Comics.
Es ist ja, es ist glaube ich ganz normal.
Das eine ist Claire Cotter, das andere ist Kiebmauer und Witsch, es ist nicht ganz so cool. Das ist ja das Fischer-Verlag-Universum, das Cinematic-Fischer-Verlag-Universum. Eigentlich gibt es das was in Deutschland halt auch so, du hast halt dann den Thomas Mann Verlag, und dann hast du halt auf der anderen Seite Clare irgendwie mit Günther Grass, und die dürfen sich auch nicht vermischen. Günther Grass kann auch nicht einen Roman in Venedig schreiben. Das geht auch nicht. Bist du eher Reklam oder Fischer? Boah, das ist hart, ey. Das ist hart. Das eine war Metropolis. Also seitdem Christopher Nolan die Filme für Reklam gemacht hat, war ich eigentlich Reklam-Fan, aber man muss schon sagen, was Fischer gerade auf die Beine steht. Obwohl, ich finde die Zack-Snyder-Fischer-Reihe auch nicht schlecht eigentlich. Ich meine, es ist ein bisschen weird geworden, irgendwie diese ganzen Sachen, von wegen der Untertanen und so, das war strange, aber gerade die Extended Edition, die 6000 Seiten lang war, fand ich schon nicht schlecht. Finde ich schon gut eigentlich.
Ich finde Reglam nicht gut, wenn die ein Größeres Format haben als die normalen Reglambücher.
Nee, ich finde das auch. Diese kleinen Bücher sind cool, die sind taschenförmig. Man kann sie in die Tasche stecken.
Aber erfahrungsgeblich werden Taschen noch gerade schmaler.
Ja, gibt es Taschen noch? Verschwinden Taschen?
Nein.
Nee? Aber man hat weniger Taschen, oder? Es gibt nicht mehr diese vieltaschigen, diese Anglerwesten und Cargo-Pants. Eigentlich bräuchte man so Gegenstände mit einer grossen Tasche. Leute mit vielen Taschen sind immer suspekt. Was ist da drin? Niemand, ja, was ist da drin? Wenn die in U-Bahnen stehen, dann kommt diese Durchsage, nehmen Sie sich in acht vor Taschendieben.
Du guckst doch so viel. Und der eine Typ mit acht Taschen, fuck, fuck.
Nee, in der einen Tasche ist ein Reklamheft drin, in der anderen Tasche habe ich einen Taschenmesser drin. Ja. So, dann guck mal alle den Typen an mit der Anglerweste, mit den vielen Taschen.
Entschuldigung, es wurde ja gerade durchgesagt, dass wir auf Taschenliebe achten sollen.
Ja!
Ich mache es so, weil ich habe ziemlich viele Taschen an mir.
Ich achte auf die Taschen, die vorne an mir sind. Können Sie vielleicht auf die Taschen achten, die auf meinem Rücken und auf der Rückseite von meiner Hose sind? Okay, ich will es nicht ganz tun. Alles klar, danke schön. Gerne. Danke schön. Das ist auch mein grösster Panikmoment, wenn jemand aufsteht im ICE und sagt, können Sie bitte auf meine Sachen aufpassen? Und ich mir immer denke, mit welcher Situation genau rechnet die Person jetzt, dass jemand angehankommt, den Laptop mitnimmt und ich mit meinem Leben diesen Laptop verteidige oder was? Ja. Was genau geschieht jetzt? So kommen dann irgendwie so ein Mann mit Maske
und so einem Sack auf dem Rücken, angeschlichen
und ich so, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey,
Moment mal! Waffe runter, Waffe runter!
Moment mal, ich werde diesen Laptop
in meinem Leben verteidigen, ich habe ihn alt geschworen,
ihn zu verteidigen! Was, machen wir uns
nichts vor, die einzige Situation,
die kommen kann, dass der Laptop, pass nicht auf meinen Laptop auf,
ne? Ja. Die einzige Situation,
wo man, der geht ja nicht aus Versehen verloren. Ne, der fliegt ja auch nicht, der rennt ja auch nicht weg. Ne, das ist ein Laptop, pass nicht auf meinen Laptop auf, ne? Die eine Situation, wo man, der geht ja nicht aus Versehen verloren. Der fliegt ja auch nicht, der rennt ja auch nicht weg. Das ist ein Laptop, der sitzt da. Es sei denn, jemand klaut ihn mutwillig. Und dann würde man den ja nicht verteidigen. Naja, aber vor allem, wenn jemand zu mir sagt, pass nicht auf meinen Laptop auf, ich bin 100% on edge, ich bin Batman auf dem Bankgiebel von Gotham, ich pass auf diesen Laptop auf und wenn ich mich selber in den Tod werfen muss, um ihn zu verteidigen, weil das wäre mir zu peinlich, wenn die Person zurückkommt in den Laptop, ja, er wurde geklaut. Er ist in die Richtung gerannt, Richtung Bordbistro. Richtung Bonn. Zurück nach Bonn. Ich verstehe es. Das ist wirklich lustig. Weil, was erwarten die denn genau? Weil das ist ja so, eigentlich ist es genau so anonym für, wenn jemand kommt und den klaut, klauen Sie ihn bitte zurück. Ringen Sie den Menschen hier nieder. Stefan, ich glaube, ich habe eine ernste Wahrheit für dich. Was die dir wirklich sagen, ist, klau du ihn nicht. Die Verdächtigen dich. Und deswegen sagen sie dir, schön, können Sie bitte auf meinen Laptop aufpassen, weil wenn er dann weg ist, dann hast du keine Ausrede mehr. Wenn du wirklich dachtest, okay, ich warte noch, bis sie aufsteht. Wir sind gleich in Osnabrück. Sobald sie aufsteht, nehme ich den Laptop und auf weg. Und wenn sie dann sagt, schön können sie auf meinen Laptop aufpassen. Fuck! Ja. Ich glaube, die Idee ist, dass der Sitznachbar nicht den Laptop klaut. Das ist eine super Idee. Das heißt aber auch, dass die Person dich verdächtigt. Aber du musst ja nicht mehr da sitzen, wenn du mir geklaut hast.
Gut.
Aber die Sitzreservierung hat halt vier Euro gekostet.
Und dein Name steckt nach oben in der Visitenkarte.
Stimmt, da steht drauf, bis wo er gebucht hat.
Und da werden alle Polizisten des Landes nach Osnabrück geschickt. Wenn du zum Klo musst in der Bahn, gehst du eher kurz nach, kurz vor oder während eines Stopps? Lang nach. Lang nach. Dass man fast Angst hat, der nächste Stopp könnte einen unterbrechen. Das macht spannend. Das ist der Kick, den ich brauche, dass ich mir denke, ich will nicht auf der Toilette sein, während die Durchsage kommt, gleich kommen wir nach Hamm.
Ne, ich bin wirklich direkt danach, weil das Problem ist direkt danach, es gibt nach der Haltestelle noch diese 20-minütige Phase, wo Leute noch bummeln und suchen und wandern und schieben und flanieren und Lustwandeln und sich treiben lassen von den Wellen des Zuges, dieser Reise, der Abteilung und sich denken, ich verdiene was Besseres als dieses Abteil. Ich habe mich hier zwar hingesetzt, aber ich habe mich nochmal umgeschaut, ich bin hier falsch, ich bin hier fehl am Platz, ich breche nochmal auf, das sind eigentlich so wie die Kolonialisten, die sagen, ich brech jetzt noch mal auf. Ich hab hier einen Platz, aber es geht besser. Es geht besser als dieser Platz und deswegen, Liebesabteil 37, stehen wir jetzt gemeinsam und alle so, pssst, stehen wir jetzt gemeinsam auf. Das ist Ruheabteil, Entschuldigung, ja, stehen wir gemeinsam auf, weil wir finden im Norden des Zuges einen besseren Platz. Woher weisst du das? Einen besseren Platz. Kannst du das garantieren? Ich hab's gesehen, Menschen mit zufriedenem Grinsen kommen aus dem Norden des Zuges und entgegen mit ihren vollgestopften Mündern. Das hast du schon gesagt, als wir hierher gezogen sind, hast du uns den Himmel vom Himmel versprochen. Ja, das habe ich euch wirklich versprochen.
Ich sehe doch die Mario-Win.
Du hast uns bessere Sprichwörter versprochen. Und was haben wir bekommen? Nichts!
Ruhe am Teil, okay? Wie gesagt.
Okay.
Das sind die wirklich mutig, das stimmt.
Ein bisschen frivoles Thema jetzt.
Erotik?
Nee.
Wird es schlüpfrig?
Oh, können wir kurz was zwischenwerfen?
Weil wir haben uns ja letzte Woche geschämt.
Ja, das stimmt.
Es war uns richtig peinlich.
Wir haben Titten gesagt im Podcast.
Ja, ich war eine ganze Woche lang rot angelaufen.
Richtig beschämt.
Wir haben uns für unsere Halberektion richtig beschämt, die wir in dem Moment hatten. Und wir haben nämlich uns überlegt. Raging Semi. Wir haben uns überlegt, wie man sich merken kann, was Stalaktiten und was Stalakmiten sind. Und zum Glück hat uns unsere extrem prüde und keusche Community ein bisschen unter die dünnen Arme gegriffen und hat gesagt, ja, da ist Bedarf, wir brauchen jugendfreie Merkhilfen. Das stimmt, ich habe noch nicht so viele Nachrichten bekommen, weil Leute wollten nicht, dass das mal in Eselsbrücke bleibt. Nee, die haben uns, glaube ich, angehört, dass uns das richtig unangenehm war. Und zwar schreibt hier mal Peter stellvertretend, und wir haben tatsächlich viele Nachrichten bekommen, und hier schreibt Peter, dass bei Stalaktit, das sind ja die, die oben sind, Stalaktit, da sieht das T aus, das grosse T wie ein von der Decke hängender Steinschnudel. Genau, wie man das ist. Und er meinte also Stalaktit für oben und Stalagmid.
Wenn man sich das M anguckt, sieht das aus wie zwei in die Höhe ragende Spitzen, wo ich sage, I call Bullshit, weil das M sieht eher aus wie ein von oben hängendes V. Das finde ich nicht. Nee, das kannst du nicht sagen. Du kannst nicht sagen, das M könnte genauso für den oben hängenden Nudel sein, weil das M ja oben in der grösseren Kluft des M's hat es ja diesen nach unten gerichteten Keil. Also ich sage Bullshit zu Stalagmit, Stalagtit nehme ich aber an, Stalagtit von oben, das grosse T, merkt euch da, Stalagtiten sind, falls ihr mal in einer Tropfhöhle seid und euch wirklich das Gesprächsthema ausgeht, was schnell passiert in Tropfsteinhöhlen, könnt ihr sagen, Stalactiten sind die, wo das grosse T nach unten zeigt, oder eine andere Eselsbrücke, falls ihr gesagt habt, die ist mir immer noch zu schlüpfrig, das hat immer noch was Fallisches, dieses T. Gut, das werden wir auch nicht los. Von der Decke Baumhände. Von Tropfsteinhöhlen, lächzenden Tropfsteinhöhlen. Ja, das ist mir zu wild, deswegen kam noch eine zweite Eselsbrücke, und zwar Stalagmiet wachsen mit mir. Das ist auch so um die Ecke. Also genau wie ich von einem kleinen Menschen zu einem grossen Menschen wachse, von unten nach oben. Die Stalagmieten wachsen mit mir. Das ist wie Stalagmieten, fängt dem N an, genau wie Marmor, den man eher unten findet. Gerne, gerne. Wir finden unendlich viel. Micha schreit auf die Gefahr, dass das schon 12.423 Leute geschrieben haben. Stalagthiten hängen in die Tiefegrüsse. Ja, mir gefällt die Name. Aber auch da, warum sollte man es nach Richtung bewerten? Weil du kannst doch sagen, Stalaktiten sind die Tiefen. Oh Gott. Warum nicht in die Tiefe? Die Richtung ist irreführend. Die Richtung ist irreführend. Ich bleib bei mir mein Hänge-Titten. Weil ehrlich gesagt, rechts und links mache ich manchmal noch Fehler. Bei Stalakmiten, Stalaktiten. Das stimmt noch nie ein Fehler gemacht. Meine Fehlerhistorie ist bei Null. Mit dieser dreckigen Kack-Eselsbrücke. Tut mir leid. Wir bereiten uns unser halbes Leben auf diese Tropfsteinhöhle vor. Ich habe das Gefühl, viele von uns werden dieses Wissen nie brauchen. Können wir mal eine Folge in der Tropfsteinhöhle aufnehmen? Ehrlich jetzt? Nee, warum nicht? Wer geht denn da gerade noch rein? Die freuen sich doch, wenn mal jemand ein bisschen PR macht für Tropfsteinhöhlen. Ja. Dann sagen wir dreimal Tropfsteinhöhle, Decksteinhöhle oder wie heißt die,
gut, besucht die mal.
In England gibt es was ganz Verrücktes,
weil da gibt es einen
Wasserfall, der kann Dinge
versteinern.
Und zwar ist in diesem Wasserstein,
ich glaube Tropfsteinhöhlen ist ja im weitesten Sinne
Kalk, ach, ich sage jetzt mal Kalk
für die Ansammlung, ja, ihr wisst,
was gemeint ist, Kalk in Anführungszeichen.
Und das kommt im Wasser
und dadurch entstehen diese
Zuerst Ich sage jetzt mal Kalk. Kalk-Ansammlung. Ja, ihr wisst, was gemeint ist, Kalk in Anführungszeichen. Und das kommt im Wasser und dadurch entstehen diese eiszapfenförmigen, dicken, prallen Stalactiten. Ja, so schwanzförmige. Und dann tropfen die und dadurch kommen die auch unten, von unten prängeln die richtig hoch. Und da ist es, wenn du in diesem Wasserfall, ist auch wahnsinnig viel kalt. Wie wachsen die von unten? Ja, wenn es oben drauf tropft. Genauso wie man so Sandburgen bauen kann mit so Schlamm. Egal, und da gibt es einen Wasserfall, wenn du da zum Beispiel einen Teddybären ins Wasser hängst, dann versteinert der, weil in dem Wasser so viel Kalk ist, dass über die Zeit nimmt der ähnlich wie Stalagmiten und Titen Steine auf. Das heißt, da kann man alles versteinern. Das ist toll. Wir machen eine Folge, nehmen wir unter dem Wasserfall auf und wer zuerst versteinert, hat verloren. Das wäre eine gute Idee. Hat mal jemand versucht, so lange stehen zu bleiben, bis er versteinert ist? Ja. Ich weiß es nicht. Locker ja. Kann ich jetzt endlich mal eine schluftige Geschichte erzählen? Können wir vielleicht noch ein Bild, vielleicht nur eine Person, vielleicht nur einer von euch, und zwar hätte ich gerne ein Bild mit einem gephotoshoppten Gesicht von Stefan, wie er auf einem oben liegenden Kalkprängel ist und einfach Stalaktize drunter. Simpel, ganz simpel, ganz simpel, ganz simpel, nicht lustig, super einfach gehalten, biertrocken, super trocken, das Ding dauert 30 Sekunden, aber auch nicht in einem Tweet irgendwie untergehend, der noch einen lustigen Gag drin hat, nein, trocken, einfach das Bild gepostet. Trocken, kommentarlos, das darf über einen Schwunzler nicht hinausgehen.
Und das sind die Limitationen, aber wäre geil, wenn es nur eine Person macht.
Nicht, dass es jetzt 20 Leute machen. Falls ihr denkt, das wird niemand anders außer mir machen, macht das. Aber nur eine Person. Ob ihr das hinkriegt, kriegt die Community das hin, dass es nur eine einzige Person einschickt. Das würden wir mal gerne testen. Das finde ich ganz gut eigentlich, ja. Also die Schuflige Geschichte ist eigentlich nur eine eine Rechtfertigung meinerseits, kennt man das nämlich, angenommen man steht in einer Schlange vorm Klo und man geht rein ins Klo und man riecht schon, oh dammit, hier ist vorher was passiert. So, wie unangenehm ist es, wenn du wieder rausgehst und da setzt jeder von uns den, nee, ich war das nicht, der Vorgänger war das Blick auf, der, aber machen wir uns nichts vor, nicht einfach umzusetzen ist. Ich denke mir, in solchen Situationen denke ich mir immer, check die Person hinter mir das. Und dann denke ich mir, wie oft habe ich schon von meinem Vordermann oder Vorderfrau verstanden, dass mir diese Person den Blick zuwirft. Noch nie. Also ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit sehr gering, dass die Person, dem ich diesen Blick zuwerfe, das versteht, auch nahe null. Deswegen ist glaube ich wichtig, also die Uhr tickt. Du gehst rein in den Moment und ab dem Moment, wo du den unangenehmen Geruch wahrnimmst, ist ein Wettlauf gegen die Zeit. Das ist mein persönliches Jack-Bauer-24-Erlebnis. Dann läuft knallhart ein fucking Countdown runter. Bam! Und ich, Hose runter. Das muss sofort losgehen. Sofort. Da darf keiner Zeit verschenken. Und wenn du merkst, kommt nicht, sofort wieder Hose an, raus! Und nochmal anstellen, direkt nochmal anstellen. Nochmal anstellen, einfach der ganzen Schlange das Gefühl geben, nie im Leben hat er Zeit gehabt, da sein großes Geschäft zu verrichten, Nummer zwei auszuüben.
Und es ist nämlich passiert, im Restaurant hat sich plötzlich eine Schlange vom Klo gebildet und ein Fan war hinter mir, ein Hörer von uns, liebe Grüße an der Stelle, hat länger mit mir gesprochen, super netter Kerl, lange in Hongkong gelebt, wir haben uns ein bisschen unterhalten. und der Mann vor mir war Sender am Klo, ich gehe rein und es war halt, ist halt diese Situation, du, wenn du mich ansprichst, ich will auch, dass du mich magst. Ja, ja, ja. So, und dann gehe ich rein aufs Klo und wir haben uns verabschiedet und ich gehe rein und merke, der Vorgänger hat da aber sowas von die Kloschlüssel lackiert. Was macht man denn dann? Und dann habe ich mir sehr, ich, alles hinter mir zu lassen, raus und zu sagen, mein Blick war auch, sorry, da würde ich jetzt nicht reingehen, aber nicht so, dass ich es war. Man muss eigentlich ultraschnell schalten und vielleicht sogar die Tür gar nicht schließen und nur die Hände waschen. Aber das geht nicht, oder war ein Waschbecken drin, oder so eine Situation mal das? Ich weiß nicht, wie du um die Welt läufst, aber ich laufe nicht. Ja, ja, vielleicht musst du dir das antrainieren, weil du gehst ja immer völlig naiv rein und denkst dir, jetzt kommt Blumenwiese, wir sind hier in einem Hain von Zitronenbäumen und plötzlich, Sekunde mal, wo bin ich denn hier? Der wird doch nicht! Du musst darauf eigentlich schon gefasst sein. Das stimmt. Was ist mit mir gefahren, dass ich nicht darauf gefasst war? Du musst sofort darauf gefasst sein. Idee. Antizipieren ist immer die Lösung. Kurz die Tür in Spalt auf, ajar, in Spalt auflassen und noch so ein, ach Gott, oh Gott, so was aussondern. Ja. So ein, ach, ja, oh, oder dann noch so einen Blick zu werfen, hinter der Schlange so ein, oh. Ja, wirklich gestikuliert. Dann beeile ich mich wohl besser. Die wedelnde Hand, ja, oh, nee, so muss sein. Nee, finde ich nicht schlecht. Was haben Sie denn hier gemacht? Tür zu. Was haben Sie denn hier? So was. Kriegt man das nicht durch die Tür noch hin? Also falls es wirklich zu spät ist, die Tür ist zu... Nein, du musst so laut deutlich sagen. Das klingt so, als hätte man selber Verstopfungen oder so. Nee, das geht nicht. Jetzt ist man schon zu spät. Viel zu übertrieben, laut. Oh mein Gott!
Und dann die Tür aufstehen und rennen. Ich meine, zur Not einfach durchs Fenster auch raus. Man kann auch gucken, kommt man einfach raus. Ich finde es so unangenehm, dass es da auch keinen Code für gibt für, das war nicht ich, das war ein Vorgänger.
Ja, es gibt ja diesen klassischen WG oder vielleicht ist das auch eine Legende mit Krawatte an der Tür, man hat Damenbesuch und so ein Ding, wo ich mich immer gefragt habe, wie läuft das? Weil du gehst dann mit deiner Begleitung nach Hause in dein Zimmer und dann holst du die Krawatte aus dem Schrank und hängst die nochmal außen dran, weil du kannst ja nicht nach Hause kommen und die Krawatte hängt schon an der Tür, weil sie dann auch denkt, also jeder kennt diesen Code, sie dann auch schon wow, du bist hier schon sehr sicher, also aber zu welchem Zeitpunkt genau kommt, ist es nur eine Highschool Romantic Comedy Legende oder ist es wirklich eine Regel? Ich dachte immer, das Problem hat vorher angefangen, dass ihr in der Räumlichkeit miteinander Geschlechtsverkehr haben wollt, wo andauernd immer jemand reinkommt. Was ist das denn für, ach so, es kommt aus diesen geteilten Dormrooms. Ah, diese Dormrooms, stimmt. Ja, ja, genau, das ist ein Punkt, den man anscheinend nicht abschliessen kann. So, und wenn du merkst, es passiert, dann auch unangenehm. Dann ist es super unangenehm. Sorry, ganz kurz, ich muss kurz, da muss man noch raus, dann sind Anzüge, wo Krawatten dran sind, ja häufig in so einem Anzugsack. Ja, vor allem schätzt man es falsch ein. Sie gibt den High Five und du yes, holst die Krawatte und sie, ich dachte, wir machen Hausaufgaben. Achso, nee, ich wollte mich nur schick machen. Achso, dann musste sie den Rest des Semesters mit einer Krawatte rumlaufen, um die Lüge aufrechtzuerhalten. Aber ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass das schon mal jemand gemacht hat oder was. Ich habe keine Ahnung. Das sind so Dinge, die man nur aus Serien und Filmen kennt, wo man auch nicht weiß, will mir hier irgendjemand einen Tipp geben? Weil ich glaube, darum geht es. Weil ich glaube, wenn jemand die Lösung, weil Serien und Filme sind ja das moderne Knigge. Es gibt ja kein Knigge mehr, sondern du hast es in Serien. So Kirby Enthusiasm, die sagen dir, was du machen sollst und was nicht. Und so, glaube ich, sind solche Serien auch, wenn man sich denkt, hey, ich habe hier mal einen Fehler gemacht in meiner Uni-Zeit, also fühle ich diese Regel mit der Krawatte und baue die in meine
Serie ein und
dann kommt es so in die Welt und man sollte das
ernst nehmen. Man sollte das ernst nehmen.
Aber auch
in alle Richtungen eigentlich ein guter Move,
zu sagen,
ich würde auch ab und zu einfach mal das raushängen,
auch wenn ich alleine abends Netflix gucke.
Einfach mal raushängen.
Gut, aber jetzt bist du wieder der Junge, der Wölfe, Wölfe ruft.
Da musst du höllisch aufpassen mit sowas.
Wieso?
Ja, irgendwann glaubt es dir keiner mehr.
Wölfe, Wölfe?
Stimmt.
Soll ich mich jetzt umdrehen? Steht da wirklich ein Wolf?
Wölfe?
Stehen da wirklich Wölfe, bin ich mich jetzt umdrehen?
Breitgrinsen auch so.
Wölfe.
Ich drehe mich jetzt, okay, dann drehe ich mich jetzt um. Ja. Du bist dir hundertprozentig sicher, dass da Wölfe stehen? Ja. Okay. Oh, schon wieder! Du bist aber einer, aber der Gag ist gut, der Gag ist gut, schon nicht schlecht. Das ist der zweitbeste Gag nach, wenn man rechts auf die Schulter tippt, aber die Person schaut sich dann rechts und man steht eigentlich links daneben. Immer lustig, immer lustig. Habe ich auch schon zu oft gemacht. Ich würde auch gerne Gags zurücknehmen. Zeitreise. Ich habe in meiner Schulzeit auch viele Gags gemacht, die ich gerne zurücknehmen würde. Ich habe mir auch manchmal unangenehme Erinnerungen ein, wo ich Sachen gemacht habe, die will ich einfach rückgängig machen. Und wenn Zeitreisen möglich sind, das machen doch Leute. Ihre Vergangenheit bügeln. Genau, nicht etwas tun, nicht Hitler töten, sondern in der einen Rallye-Nachhilfestunde vielleicht nicht irgendwie versuchen, dem Papier aus der letzten Reihe in den Mülleimer zu werfen. Und es funktioniert nicht, du wirst nicht treffen. Du wirst nie treffen. Ich würde sagen, pass auf, wir machen kurz mit, wir reisen kurz mit mir in die Vergangenheit, so, wir kommen mal in die Schule an, so, es ist gleich 12.15, fünfte Stunde so ungefähr, ihr seht mich laufen, die Kamera folgt mir, ich laufe den Korridor lang, ich weiß genau, wo der Raum war, wo ich Deutschunterricht hatte zu dem Zeitpunkt, ich deute euch so an, kommt mit Kamera, folgt mir. Ja, folgt ihr. Renn rein, ich schleiche mich in den Raum, das läuft gerade Unterricht schon, alle gucken nach vorne, war ein spannender Lehrer, stellt gute Fragen und es sind irgendwie spannend, alle gucken zu, da ist auch keiner, wo du mal eben wegdösen kannst. Das heißt, ich kann mich einigermaßen gut reinschleichen in den Raum, folgt mir, so, dann krabbel ich über den Boden, mach diesen Army, weiss nicht, Raupengang mit den Ellenbogen. Ich laufe vor allem über meine Ellenbogen und Knie. Robbe mich nach vorne zu mir. Fuck, Kaugummi, damn it. Er hat mich nie nachgesehen? Nee, ich glaube nicht. Ich robbe mich zu mir, ich sass irgendwo am Rand und sage nur zu mir, Psst, ja, wer bist du denn? Und ich sage nur diesen einen Sat satz sag jetzt gleich nicht auf gar keinen fall sagst du mello sag nicht aber es ist richtig so und ich gehe wieder raus und dann sagt der pakete deutschlehrer die frage so jetzt zählt mir mal ein paar romantische Maler auf. Sag nicht Claude Mello.
Und dann sagt er, das ist ein Wein, alle lachen. Ja, da habe ich keine Lust drauf. Nee. Und er fragt, Zeit zählt Maler auf und mein Arm schnellt in die Höhe Mello. Ja. Kein Maler. Das möchte ich nicht. Das möchte ich erasen.
Und du steigst zurück in deine Zeitmaschine, kommst wieder in der Gegenwart an und die Wissenschaftler und haben sich Hitler getötet? Ist er tot? Ist die Welt gerettet? Ja. Oh, danke. Die Mission war erfolgreich. Wuhuuu! Sie schauen aus der Tür und es ist einfach nur so riesige, stapfende Dinosaurier, die die Wellen auseinanderreissen.
So ein Hochhaus abreissen. Godzilla mit so einem Wein in der Hand. Das frisst Köln. Das ist der peinlichste Moment an der Geschichte, Claude Mello. Nee, nee, nee. Das ist schon irgendwie hängen geblieben. Ist nicht so peinlich, aber würde ich gerne verändern. Heute ist mir eingefallen, heute Morgen, dass ich früher mal meine Verwandten aber bitte mit Sahne gesungen habe. Aber ohne den Song jetzt wirklich gut zu kennen. Ich habe den davor ein, zwei Mal gehört. Das Selbstbewusstsein. Ja, irre. Ich habe den ein, zwei Mal davor gehört. Melodie nicht fest in mir drin, habe den aber gesungen, weil ich den Text irgendwie hatte, und habe deswegen laut gesungen, das würde ich auch gerne erasen, singen nicht, auf gar keinen Fall, aber bitte mit Sahne. Okay, aber wie, also was war die Situation? Setting, Familienfeier. Ich würde jetzt gern was singen. Setting war Familienfeier, unten hatten wir, weil ich auch in einer Band gespielt habe, damals schon, mit dem Kumpel ein bisschen Musik gemacht hat, da waren wir noch ganz klein, mein Vater hatte so eine coole Anlage gekauft und da war auch ein Mikrofon konnte man anschliessen und dann hatte ich ein Jürgens Album, wo dann ein Text hinten drauf war und dann habe ich aber bitte mit Sahne, lauthals für alle Verwandten. Ich habe wirklich gesagt, kommt mal runter in den Keller, ich singe euch das, grauenhaft mit so sechs, sieben, acht. Oh, die höchste Fallhöhe, die man sich nur vorstellen kann, die Person selber, nicht dass jemand sagt, Stefan, du kannst doch so gut singen, mach mal. Nein, die Person selber, du wirst sogar abgehalten, Eltern sagen, bist du, wie sicher? Und du, ja, ja, klar, kommt her. Und wenn man sagt, ne, mach das doch erst nach dem Nachtisch, bitte. Wollte ich sehen. Aber bitte mit Sahne.
Apropos
verschiedene Timelines, noch ganz kurzer Abriss
von Leuten, die uns geschrieben haben, die gesagt haben,
sie gehen all in, sie probieren mal was aus.
Ich habe keine Erinnerung an diesen Aufruf.
Ja, ich glaube, viele Leute haben das auch falsch verstanden,
weil wir haben gesagt, macht mal was
mehr oder weniger Sinnloses, geht
einfach mal all in auf irgendein Projekt.
Macht mal ein Segelschein mässig. Ja, ja, versucht wirklich mal die Timeline zu ändern, so womit niemand rechnet. Und es haben Leute geschrieben, jemand versucht jetzt gerade Französisch zu lernen oder hat sich den Rubik's Cube angelernt. Das ist alles cool, aber das ist ja noch halbwegs sinnvoll so. Wenn du Französisch lernst, das versteht jeder, findet jeder cool. Aber ich finde eine Person, deren Namen ich leider nicht finde, aber du weißt, wer gemeint ist, er hat uns geschrieben und ich finde, da ist völlig die Hausaufgabe richtig aufgegangen. Und zwar hat er gesagt, er hat angefangen, seinen Rucksack falsch rumzutragen. Ja, und da sage ich, yes, das ist mal wirklich all in gehen, weil da ist Ausgang ungewiss. Man weiss nicht, was dabei rauskommt. Das sind die Innovatoren, die Triebkräfte, die unsere Gesellschaft braucht. Ich weiß auch nicht genau, was er mit Falschrum meint. Meint er vorne auf dem Bauch oder meint er mit Öffnung nach unten? Ich weiß es nicht genau. Beides interessant. Und wenn du sogar vorne mit Öffnung nach unten nimmst, du bist eine Legende. Also alle Kraft zu dir, ich wünsche dir viel, viel Erfolg. Halt uns auf dem Laufenden.. Ja, und an alle anderen nochmal mit diesem sehr vagen Aufruf, geht mal all in, im Sinne von Sternchen, Sternchen eins, Asterisk, im Sinne von macht mal was, was jetzt noch niemand anderes macht, im Sinne von Welt verändern, mal rumprobieren. Aber was auch nicht nützlich ist, wo sich der Nutzen nicht sofort ergibt.
Vielleicht bald.
Genau, geschwungene Klammer zu.
Wir geben dieselben Hausaufgaben nochmal auf für nächste Woche, ihr kriegt das hin, haut rein.
Macht's gut.
Ciao, ciao, wir heben ab.
It's a Wallisbury production.